[Music]
like to me i'm looking to be happy and
like i have unlimited
knowledge of people making less than
100k making less than 50k that are are
happy like i have buddies that i grew up
with that are like pumped making 80k a
year nice salary some nice salaries i
hate when people like 80 like the
world's [ __ ] up like 80k like if you
don't now if you don't if you live
within your means
but like by the way 80k comes with a lot
less pressure do you understand what my
life is i wake up i go right to my phone
offices in singapore offices and [ __ ]
you know in in mexico city i have 45 20
employees that are
that are ukrainian and russian do you
understand what i'm dealing with today
like when you like diddy and biggie that
hold mo money more problems that's real
[ __ ] bro
like like i don't envy being like i'm
actually upset that i'm my alpha one
i'd rather be a number four how how long
have you been
trying
to buy the jets and what's stopping you
is it is it the money what is it uh
since fifth grade which was the year i
realized that i couldn't play for the
jets so i pivoted
i have such good hand-eye coordination
that in second first third grade i was
confused i was like the best athlete
because i was just at my hand icon like
even now like i remember in college my
buddies are like you play darts i'm like
no i don't [ __ ] play darts i come and
hang out play darts i'm like okay and
[ __ ] destroyed their face like i've
really ping-pong all the hand-eyed [ __ ]
i'm dominant fifth grade is when speed
size athleticism agility started to
become a factor so i was like god damn
it i can't do this so
uh what's stopping me now is the money
the fact that the johns i don't have it
yet yeah uh the johnson family isn't
selling
um that's it what's the price what's the
price on that team you think i think by
the time like i think they're i think if
i buy the jets it happens
in 15 or 20 years
um
i i mean who the [ __ ] knows i mean i
think if the jets went up for sale today
you're looking at seven billion
are you changing that stadium because
met life's a [ __ ]
i would probably move it the if you know
if i buy the jets there's it's a weird
thing i'm a jersey boy
right
um
i hate the giants like i hate them like
it's insane i despise the giants
um so the thought of sharing a stadium
with them especially when everyone
that's old still calls a giant stadium
i'm like glad you called it metlife i'm
like okay uh
i
but when i immigrated from russia we
lived in queens when i first got here
and i i'd be lying if i didn't say that
i've thought about the concept of moving
the jets back to queens if i buy them so
i'm not sure
like again i'm 20 years from now my
life's going to be different the world's
going to be different who the [ __ ] knows
what i might put them on the [ __ ]
moon you know like
so so uh but but yes i think given how
old the stadium will be when i roughly
feel that i'll be in striking distance i
do think i'll have an option to do some
[ __ ]
with your like business stuff right
obviously you know you do the tick tock
videos and you're obviously very
successful and going all the way back to
the wine library right like how you kind
of started it it blew up but in general
what percentage do you equate to
um
like people being lucky
as well as like you have to be good so
like
do you do you think that there's there's
definitely right place right time with a
lot of things like you look at dave with
barstool right like
he had to be good because he was he's
talented determined like fighting bums
to hand out newspapers but by the same
token
20-year run of tom brady mix in the red
sox the celtics that kind of plateau him
so like
my intuition is that portnoy's energy he
would have done something else and we'd
be talking about him being lucky that
coffee was cool or that like sledding
got hot you know like got it here's
where i'm at with so luck yes
i was born in the soviet union i got
lucky that i was able to leave during
that era where my grandfathers both went
to jail for [ __ ] a decade for being
jewish in russia and like for being
entrepreneurs and here i'm a [ __ ]
hero so yes
here's the problem if you're watching
this show and you use luck as a weapon
you [ __ ] lost
if you sit around and say dave's lucky
sarah's lucky ricky's lucky youtube
three [ __ ] are lucky if you use luck
as a weapon you're [ __ ]
because you're using it as a medicine to
make yourself feel better that you're
not winning
and that's a very tough mindset i don't
i don't envy that i actually have a lot
of compassion for it i'm not razzing i'm
empathetic i think we should talk about
it
because when you're using luck
everyone's like
any [ __ ] person that's born in
america you're [ __ ] lucky
like like like there's 850 million
people on earth that don't have access
to clean water
like i love when people are like in
america drinking a six dollar coffee on
their thousand dollar iphone tweeting
you're lucky you're [ __ ] lucky
that's a good point gary oh i have a lot
of good points my man
you know i i had this question and i was
thinking about it on the train here
i know you're big into the nft game i'm
big into the sports cards me too i was
bidding [ __ ] crazy on that kobe
bryant sports illustrated i've seen that
yeah i wanted that [ __ ]
i was the runner up to that [ __ ] i'm
pissed what would you say to like a
like a let's say a 13 year old kid would
you would you say for that kid to both
both you would say yeah this is what's
so funny about the world everyone's
obsessed with or
when the answer is always and
gotcha right like you know the card guys
are like [ __ ] you
like nft people like yo real world is
dead the real world's staying forever
but the digital world's very real let's
not get confused and they both coexist
and like people give a [ __ ] about having
a [ __ ] blue check mark on instagram
and people care about [ __ ] getting a
fat ass [ __ ] north face to rock like
we're it's we're in a both world i was
weird you brought that up because i just
you know i just got both i just got the
uh the north face and i just got the
check mark on instagram i love it listen
i i do my homework coming on these
[ __ ] shows
[Laughter]
um
you've seen i've seen a lot of videos of
you with like yard sales and just kind
of searching vintage stuff and you talk
about kobe bryant like chances are you
you but when no one thought cards were
big 15 20 years ago you could have saved
that what is i guess like in your adult
life but more so as a kid what is like
the goat toy
or card or like
jacket or fashion thing you wish you
saved because obviously now you have the
money you can go buy it now but it's not
the same as like hey i saved like an
untouched pair of jordan ones from 85
because i had the foresight or like
ninja turtle you know what i mean like
what with some stuff you wish you saved
being like hey i held on to that forever
as a kid
ah that's a great [ __ ] question um
i bought most of it in the 90s at garage
sales but what it was was my ljn rubber
wrestling figures from the 80s
specifically macho man king kong bundy
kamala
so
that was like my like that 1990 frank
thomas leaf rookie card that's another
goat for me
uh my altoon starting lineup
is a goat for me
um
and probably uh sound
uh
sound wave uh um
the uh transformer
and boba fett
the original star wars figure
those are probably my goats
why frank thomas
i was a humongous baseball card dealer
when i was a kid like like like on some
[ __ ] whiz kid [ __ ]
like making two thousand dollars
selling baseball cards a weekend when i
was like 14. i was you know like like
back to like not being in fifth grade
having to pivot like
back to luck
i believe i was my parents had sex at
the right second and made me a naturally
great entrepreneur i don't [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] did i do right like i'm just really
good at it and so i was really good at
sports cards and my prime was 1990 91
92. and frank thomas 90 leaf was like
the [ __ ] it card even more than the
griffey rookie that a lot of people talk
about like when i was in it that was
like the [ __ ] 70 rookie that was just
like it was just the card
okay interesting what's the best card
you got right now gary sports card i
have some serious [ __ ] now i've spent
some real money uh
i mean i have a
i have
some
very high grade george miken 1948 bowman
rookies that are
six figure cards
um
bill russell
rookie i have some basketball stuff
that's very very very valuable what's
your take on uh psa you know they're
starting to
charge people it's a main amount of
money insane amount of money to grade
these cards and i feel like it's really
unfair is that are they you know i'm a
little out of the loop because i've been
so in a coma of nfts for the last 14
months but i thought
correct me if i'm wrong so when i when i
got re-serious in 1718 obviously it was
not very expensive then the whole hobby
blew up
and then there was all the shortage and
the backlog and i thought it got very
very very expensive yeah am i am i
incorrect that it it's come down from
that craziness and are you saying it did
come down but it's still expensive it's
it did come down but you know i remember
when it used to cost you know 20 bucks
to grade a card and now if you have
let's say a lebron james rookie card
they go off the value of what that card
is and charge you their price so i think
it's really unfair what they're doing
yeah the good news is the free market
will adjust so to your point if sgc if i
say like then you'll get startups i mean
some first of all let there be no
confusion
we are going to have computerized
grading ai grading
somebody's building a [ __ ] fax
machine scanner like some sort of piece
of technology that is 100 going to
change our industry
it makes too much sense the ai
technology will be able to do all the
things that a human can't catch but
they're i don't give a [ __ ] who the best
creator in the world is at psa they're
not beating a [ __ ] robot that's true
so i think one of the things i think a
lot about because i put real [ __ ]
paper into cards is when i have to
regrade it in 15 years for the and it
could be psa it could be somebody else
i hope my 10 week stays
you know you know like some shit's gonna
go down
that's a good point do you do you have
to i mean this is kind of a crazy
question
and you probably spoke against it but
like i guess work balance or like do you
agree
you have to be on all the time like do
you watch a movie every once in a while
you watch a [ __ ] program like do you
break it up where you're like hey i just
need to what yeah
listen
my point is
when i'm on the field i'm going hard so
i sleep eight hours a day
every like people like you know my
energy [ __ ] people up and when i'm
working i'm [ __ ] actually working
like i'm not sitting around
finding some funny video on youtube and
then on a text drive with my college
buddies for an hour and a half about it
and then taking an hour lunch and like
all the [ __ ] that my employees and other
people do you know like which i'm
pathetic to when i say my employees i
love it like do your thing like i'm
you're not trying to own vaynermedia i
don't need you i hate when [ __ ]
bosses are like they should work like me
i'm like then give them the same amount
of money dick
like i hate that sense so for me
yeah oh i i mean
not only do i completely tune out for
every sporting event right like when the
jets do their little 24 7 on youtube
right jets were like i watched that [ __ ]
like i love documentaries especially
sports like sports is a great outlet for
me my family's a great outlet like a
good dinner with like the fam like love
that [ __ ] the most um
yeah i mean my communication style i'm a
high energy dude back to dna like like i
love when i like put out content people
like cocaine adderall and all my real
friends who know me laugh because they
know i haven't even smoked a cigarette
let alone all that [ __ ] and so i just
have a lot of natural gratitude
excitement optimism fire
ambition hope i just have that
you think you can get talking to like
your college buddies
um like staying in touch with people who
are just like the average joe do you
think you can get perspective of them or
like a situation
you're having trouble in business or
you're trying to figure something out
and they're like
idea or they're like
input in it you think you could get like
perspective from people not connected
like that or on the outside that can
help you become a better person or a
better boss that's a great question i i
actually easily do i think it's
audacious and ludicrous for somebody who
has had professional success think that
like somebody that like
my brain works a little bit different i
don't think success is defined by your
bank account you don't mean miserable
millionaires i know
like to me i'm looking to be happy and
like i have unlimited
knowledge of people making less than
100k making less than 50k that are are
happy like i have buddies that i grew up
with that are like pumped making 80k a
year nice salary that's a nice salaries
i hate when people are like 80 like the
world's [ __ ] up like 80k like if you
don't now if you don't if you live
within your means
but like by the way 80k comes with a lot
less pressure do you understand what my
life is i wake up i go right to my phone
offices in singapore offices and [ __ ]
you know in in mexico city i have 45 20
employees that are that are ukrainian
and russian do you understand what i'm
dealing with today like when you like
diddy and biggie that whole mo money
more problems that's real [ __ ] bro yeah
like
i don't envy being like i'm actually
upset that i'm an alpha one
i'd rather be a number four
yeah you know like i'm a [ __ ]
firefighter when i have to fill out the
[ __ ] you know immigration forums when
i go into other countries and they're
like occupation i literally write
firefighter because when you're at the
top of a [ __ ] big company when you're
doing when you're out there the way i am
where everyone's gonna have opinions and
feelings on you you're just [ __ ]
taking
punches all day
yeah that's kind of what i meant like
you walk into a dinner and your buddy
joe who like is a policeman or a [ __ ]
union like and you're like you come in
you're all pissed off you're obviously
happy to see him but you're like he's
like what's the matter you're like well
[ __ ] i'm having a problem with jerry
like he's not communicating with the
sales team this is
and he's like yeah
the answer is yes comma for full
transparency i'm a cocoon guy what i
mean by that is when my shit's [ __ ] up
i don't burden anybody else
i go to the lab i stay in my [ __ ]
head and i figure that [ __ ] out
but by the same token do you think
that's contradictory to what you just
said like if you just gave him little
pieces of info jerry might be like i
don't know okay
because i think the answer is yes and
many times even though i'm a cocoon some
[ __ ] slips out sometimes people give you
sometimes you don't ask people they tell
you i'm picking up signals all the time
look there's a tremendous advantage i
have i was
i came from the dirt
when you live in a studio apartment with
seven family members in queens and have
no [ __ ] money you're from the dirt
right and so i and i was happy
in my childhood and we had dick
so when you know that money isn't
happiness because your childhood was
built on you're happy as [ __ ] but you
got nothing
well then you're [ __ ] set
even the scenario you said i don't
really give a [ __ ] i don't get upset
that much at business it's not that
important
parents being ill scares the [ __ ] out of
me friend being hurt scares the [ __ ] out
of me somebody being sick that i love
scares the [ __ ] of me dies forget it
travesty i have a friend that i grew up
with right now hospice it's [ __ ] me
up every hour losing a million bucks
even when i had nothing losing money
[ __ ] money
i'll take it i'm trying to buy the jets
i understand the contradiction i'm
playing my game but i feel like an
athlete
like i'm on the court an entrepreneur
i'm on the [ __ ] court i'm trying to
drop 60 on your ass
but it's still a [ __ ] game
no it's a good perspective yeah no it's
why everything's easy for me
right like i want to win i want to be
the honestly on the record on the
[ __ ] mt on the [ __ ] mjt i want to
be the greatest entrepreneur of all time
i want when everyone's wrapping it up
and drinking beers at the retirement
home at 19 and getting to entrepreneur
talk in our age group watching this i
want them to be like vaynerchuk
but
it doesn't really matter
like i don't think i'm better than
anybody because i'm good at business who
gives a [ __ ]
yeah no it's a good perspective i mean
sometimes it gets in the way here i
guess you would like everybody here
you're obviously trying to you see what
we do you're trying to raise yourself
and i'm pumped for you why the [ __ ] do
you think i said yes to this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah
but i know this show you guys are gonna
leverage that i was on the show and get
bigger guests and that's what i want for
you thank you and why not why not give
[ __ ] karma to other people appreciate
it
okay yeah uh appreciate it thank you
very much
[Music]